just play it smart out there tonight
boys okay we got Thomas all on the night
one the most brilliant economist in the
world
YouTube's just itching for a reason to
monetize I so want to see a lot of hard
work out there okay crying out loud we
know how to bring the laughs let's just
play it smart cloth tickle now we need
this win denied come on let's play heads
up out there
man for man we're better than a 4z yeah
all right z4z we're burning in late
night show in the world
[Music]
[Music]
you know what Dan said is back to the
Hawking ah so good to have you that's
the sound of the weekend the last show
of the week and I couldn't be more
grateful
unbelievable showing up today Thomas
soul is on the show oh look
discrimination and disparities accounts
with the change my mind
red and white they're one of the minute
one of the men I want to have on the
half on one of the men I've wanted to
have on the show that's a great start
I'm sure but you just appeared on this
program I talked about in said before
since I met you even wanted him on the
show
yeah I've really wanted to have him on
the show which actually it leads me to a
question of the day who would you most
like to see on the show as far as you
know great minds who do you consider to
be some of the most I guess formidable
minds of our time I would certainly say
Thomas Sol on there and then in the
comedy realm nor McDonald so we're
holding out hope and then a second
question have you noticed the incredibly
odd coverage of the YouTube shooting
which we'll talk about later
and finally does anyone else have
allergies I feel as though an entire
field of dandelions just decided to line
up and flatulate right in my eyeball I
don't know anyone else out there who's
gonna be in video studios always a Jared
who is not gay following on Twitter not
get you to meet us cry with you how much
it's not your Photoshop side fulfil my
league obligations during conclusions
are we good another day not gay good and
simplified wine calm a simmer yeah
that's a thing at G Morgan Jr Harry sir
we've got the one of the day is baby
bear baby bear yeah well that's actually
perfect as Benjamin is going to be on
and there's no longer a lot on Twitter
but you are soft my friend so you even
speak into the microphone or adjust your
volume statue computer are you ready for
the overlays beep beep I'm ready and
also I'm not kool-aid on Twitter I know
you were telling me that you were very
concerned about its cult followers
already know on the show by the way he
was I guess I'll be I don't know if he's
been completely removed from Twitter we
just we just he was I just write some of
these jokes this morning yeah and then
after that he was just perma banned yeah
I think he's probably man I don't know
this is a good device to book I see when
people to holes is my host or like this
book are you gonna throw it at asleep I
get why all these leaders like you know
anybody well Oprah has her face on the
cover of every magazine since right
exactly
hey by the way case you know next month
Oh magazine she's on the cover all right
no other news reverse for those who are
who are who are chomping at the bit you
can get your free bucket of poop at an
upcoming Detroit Zoo event always try to
my home
town this comes from Emma live.com the
first thousand people at the zoo's sixth
annual green fest will receive a token
good for one free five gallon bucket of
detroit zoo poop and that's why the free
proof detroit zoologist specified
because some tap water wasn't available
i this is just this is exactly what you
would expect from detroit particularly
if you've seen how they've branded their
their local tourism campaign detroit zoo
come for the animals leave was a little
piece of Detroit for a taste that's Pure
Michigan theme song it's terrible is
right behind it it just it just makes
anything sound good yeah yeah slow
motion yeah this address rules its Pure
Michigan genius watch people who live in
Michigan shiver love that people who who
don't have no idea what we're talking
about it's a tortoise exactly and Tim
how nobody makes fun of Tim Allen on my
name that movie liner I guess sort of
series line by the way hey here's
another strike a woman said in
ancestry.com DNA test told her that she
had a different father who happened to
be her parents fertility doctor the test
showed that her DNA matched a sample
from a doctor more than five hundred
miles away at the time Rowlett was not
aware that more than 36 years ago her
parents had struggled to conceive
there's a twist seeking more information
mr. Elliott had her older sister take
the same test only to discover DNA match
with the milkman her younger sister
matched with the mailman and
unsurprisingly her youngest brother who
wears a leather helmet matched positive
with the hobo who pees down the elevator
shaft claiming he's Jesus it's always
the crazy person who claims these Jesus
from 2018 oh yeah by the way I'm Jesus
really good know I've been this weekend
my contact information these explains
why every doctor's visit was accompanied
by chocolate and roses and Astroglide
perfectly
you were saying this technically
technically the fertility doctor did his
job you can't take that away from him
all sales are final
I think the bed to the mother
rationalizing that do you do you know
where your good genes come from now
here he charges I don't think this was a
redneck family and I actually I resent
that presumption
yeah probably Arkansas if standards
let's get lighter because this news has
been so heavy let's watch this Russian
postal drone smash into a wall in its
inaugural flight roll clip our mail will
be a sight to behold for entire oh
[Laughter]
goodness is in Russia it's a flat rate
for next day killing ha ha ha in an
unsurprising turn of events the drone
turned out to be manned by the only
Chinese drone pilot in Russia so I know
someone's gonna stacked up and say
they're not pilots if they're Manning in
drones here's the thing we don't care
know some people saying that's racist
maybe a japanese couple apologize for
ignoring their work pregnancy timetable
by conceiving quote before their turn
this comes from The Telegraph Japanese
work her I don't think we have I don't
think we want to break the name because
you know she deserves her yeah yeah
that's the problem she needs to worry
about
she's been reprimanded by her boss for
selfishly breaking the rules after she
became pregnant before was her turn the
couple formally met with the director to
apologize about the pregnancy in person
and they actually did it before that by
phone and we have the exclusive audio of
that call people ask me you get these
exclusive calls but why don't they speak
in their native tongue it's always in
English so is English it's it's just as
Vexen to us yeah my way yeah yourselves
the same thing I'm super Titus said they
have all the same freedoms of Japan so
yes they do don't let this story the
idea we'll talk about the YouTube
shooting and just some overall startling
statistics that are ignored by the media
people should go and watch the John Lott
interview yesterday but a great example
is this this idea that controlling guns
will reduce suicides Japan has I think
some of the strictest gun control in the
world the highest suicide rate in the
industrialized world I believe that's
because I have to have babies in turn
yeah you once told me that if you were a
judge Quebec separately as its own
country as opposed to a province that I
would have number two I haven't been
able to find sources on that if someone
can send that to me a desk router I've
heard it I cannot substantiate it but
I've heard that multiple times in
Switzerland as well like really high I
have never heard of that I thought it
was spend computer do you know if that's
true or not they're pretty close we
can't annex them he's thinking about the
next war speaking of an acting said the
rest of the world it's time for this
week's eye on India segment
[Music]
why do we single out India because it's
a terrible place visitor and also
because people like to act as though
it's not they go there and spiritual
quests so you know what we'd like to
warn you this is why would somebody
storm India every time we do it we're
global we're globalists when it comes to
news according to an Indian professor do
you guys read this article yeah this is
great and a doctor from what I hear
women who wear jeans give birth to
transgenders and autistic children India
today
Rajeev Kumar a botany lecturer so he's
staying in his Lane accolade Eastern
kara college said on television a woman
who dresses up like a man a woman who
dresses up like a man what will the
character of the child she gives birth
to be these children are called
transgenders or nipple Khan Comstock
come see he he also later added that and
the women who wear miniskirts should
call me if science very self-serving
toll-free it what's funny is he was
adamant about his opinion we have from
the same article speaking on a TV show
recently he defended his remarks
doubling down saying they were based
quote on science and years of experience
which in his defense we believe stems
from the recently published double-blind
placebo-controlled Wranglers make [ __ ]
study I can search that one on PubMed my
eyes are still in question me yes faded
glory why are you picking on India that
story right that's exactly what I'm
making it too easy India he's on
television although they probably look
at our country with this next story and
say you don't know to I say okay you got
a point because Robert DeNiro says that
there's no use in reaching across the
aisle at all to Trump supporters though
in a recent interview he said the people
that I care about all those young people
who demonstrated their the future they
know they say we'll remember November
they're the ones who feel the way we do
not the way the gun lovers and the NRA
do with all that idiocy to the point of
absurdity he then said we're at a point
with all of us where that's beyond where
this is beyond trying to see another
person's point of view there are ways
you can talk about that or at a point
where the things that are happening in
our country are so bad and it comes from
Trump he went on citing examples blaming
Trump of course for a lackluster economy
political divisiveness as well as rocky
and Bowl
Winkle Stardust analyze that
hide-and-seek the family grudge match
the intern the big wedding dirty grandpa
Meet the Fockers Little Fockers his
entire post 2006 catalog aside from
silver linings playbook and alimony
slash child support to two ex-wives you
you're a bad president I don't think
that's a yes it is it's the bad
president at best I've heard people
describe intern as cute yeah which is
the last review raving review any
director wants to hear also the first
time Anne Hathaway has been associated
with anything called cute yeah yeah how
do you feel about the Godfather it's
cute cute that's right that's what we
were going for personality yes alright
speaking which we have to move on to our
dive inside the YouTube shooting it's
odd isn't it that we we're not talking
about her at all yeah it was as quickly
as it came it went Keyser söze it's just
gone like if I didn't win her so
everything everything we know like that
like the pollen in my eyes oh I don't
have a watch people are saying um coke
[Laughter]
fix the Danny Lyons everything yes to
fix it that's that's everyone knows it's
the antidote it's add to cope with you
fly antidotes in the most surprising
places like stake snake venom needs just
a different different kind of snake
venom pollen cocaine plant
it's another plane it's natural right
that's the look it's natural men what's
those cocaine I don't fool around with
anything synthetic just cocaine for this
cowboy
none of that methamphetamine I don't
know where that's been pure coke uh
everything we know about it
okay know some Dom xxx Adamo my
pronouncing that cred correctly there
spend computers at the pronunciation I
think so yeah there we go
yeah great I feel great that I go I go
to you for my information to make sure
that I'm correct I think so not really
sure my mind was somewhere else I was
thinking about how he screwed up
throughout history we really haven't
gotten the Trier replace him with Google
home yes wipe our history 39 years old
Iranian heritage PETA activist vegan she
wounded three shot herself as we call it
a happy ending
so uh happy she shot herself uh and also
by the way forensic scientists believe
the damage could have been much worse
had she had any b12 in her body or if
she were a man women aren't even good
masters so here's a mamey mess you does
you haven't and by the way for everyone
wondering what what happened here
there's there's a there's a lot of
evidence strong evidence that this
shooter had a problem with mental
illness don't believe me two ears tail
the tape
hello FBI I have a yeah she looks like
Michael Jackson in transition I and when
she looks like Michael Jackson after
it's a transition in a parallel universe
where the surgery was conducted with
nothing more than spent up garbage parts
from a salvage yard us so one thing that
really struck me and this is why I'm
really curious what the rest of you have
noticed is the difference now the media
covered this versus other shootings have
you guys seen this they're still talking
about parkland no mention of Sutherland
Springs no one mentioned the YouTube
shooting at all it was the biggest the
second biggest tech company I guess the
first biggest tech company because it's
Google yeah but YouTube right behind
Facebook I think the biggest website is
Google than Facebook and then YouTube I
believe number one two and three so
barely shooting at the number three
arguably number one tech company no
headlines already gone two days look at
the HuffPo in the last story on MSNBC
you can see this here and as something
that I loved about Huffington Post they
said look they go motives still unclear
notice one thing it's the police officer
they don't even show her mugshot they
don't even show her picture anytime it's
a male shooter white male shooter it's
just Dylan roof it's right up there this
is the faith face of domestic terrorism
now they just show the cop because like
let's show the white male involved in
our reporting as well because every time
I go to a comic book movie now I just
assume it's full of mass shooters
because they they'll look like they all
like the mass shooter yeah it should
mean you don't see many of this uh
what's her name miss Sam AG dham dham
probably not gonna be in Avengers age of
Ultron oh she did um or didn't have
energy as something else it was also
really striking I didn't notice a lot of
people writing about this Mashable let's
see if you can spot the difference here
between the actual picture and Mashable
yep yeah well that's that they lightened
this again and her eyes even the face
get the skin is one thing that's like
okay maybe that's just a filter maybe
there's Instagram that bad boy but the I
colored I the filter they took their
iphone wand and put it that was the
whole one that was meant to remove
redeye now we're just gonna change the
actual Tanner for us it's very
reminiscent a miss Stacy her name is
Stacy now and she transitioned to Stefan
white male terrorist reminiscent all of
this I think of it remember the Fort
Lauderdale shooting I don't remember
this I was beside myself
Esteban Santiago's who's labeled a white
Hispanic I don't know what that means
oh my god white Hispanic and of course
part of the reason for this difference
is that it didn't for the narrative of
the white male shooter which is what the
leftist media loves to claim is the
trend this doesn't go with it another
clip oh you know going up oh it's like
that dancing baby gift when the internet
first started combined or the child's
nightmare was about it makes me feel so
much better about this show production
buddies way up here it does you said you
had something you wanted to say on this
well I didn't this happened in
California I mean correct me if I'm
wrong but strong gun pretty strict gun
laws there in California also by the way
YouTube Google not not a hotbed for gun
culture which is also just even more
damning because you sent a woman into a
virtually gun-free State and she still
couldn't come up with anything she did
injure three people yes but she shot
herself yes
UH one print by the way no listen I it's
always sad when someone knows his life
but not equally sad when you gotta be
one one yeah when you shooting at other
people it's like I mean this way if I
had the power if I could do that what do
you call the pot is it ESP what's the
power you can actually control people
with your minds if I'd the Jedi that's
if I were there at YouTube that's
exactly what I would do if she were
shooting at people I'd go the breaks
Thomas all coming up after the break one
trend is that we do see is that just
like the parklands shooting for aurora
we are looking for actual trends police
were warned beforehand yeah but did
nothing now to be fair they claimed that
they didn't have any reason to detain
her and that's that's obviously if you
can't just detain someone for no reason
so again tail the tape
[Applause]
yeah I mean what does it take for their
house and bring him to the quiet room
with the white jack and the arms crossed
let me get her an intern or something
and for crying out loud the standards
have become so stringent in a long time
ago you know you said the fridge was
talking to you they put you in a pool
and gave you electroshock therapy this
frauds uploading like it's her job I
can't do anything that is a hard balance
though obviously people you can't you
can't infringe on people's rights just
because someone says she's crazy Fred
listen I don't know a whole lot about
Iran this could be the norm for all we
know she could be batting a hundred for
non-crazy Iranians I have no idea I know
about her and achma dinner John and
Annie Cyrus and she seems normal so I
guess that's the only contrast the real
trend and we'll talk about this trial
was with Thomas so after this whoa
what do you think this had it what it
wasn't white male no it wasn't politics
wasn't religion what do you think this
has had in common with other mass
shootings ninety-eight percent of public
mass shootings in fact gun-free zone it
was committed in a gun-free zone also
something else that we don't talk about
do you know you know another another
commonality here notice that it was
stopped by someone with a gun yes bad
person with a gun usually stopped by a
good person with a gun either a good
Samaritan a police officer in this case
bad girl turned good girl when she shot
herself because she took out the perp
was taken out yes where is the person
who killed Hitler having her he'll think
about it spends conflicted he's like oh
I know what I should say if I want to
stand my visa but I know how I feel
committed to the gun-free zone and
something I was stopped by someone with
a gun which might explain why this
person who was there at the shooting
well let him explain it for himself
what's going through your mind with I
mean people dropping being shot multiple
times bullets whizzing people bleeding
what's going through your mind
well Leslie was on my mind but at the
same time I knew you know I had to be
smart you know you got to be smart you
got to be fast
I think fatzke smart I don't have a gun
on me but wish I did
mmm by the way then you must not expect
that voice to come out of that yes he's
like you got to be fast I'm like you
look like an Okinawan fisherman well you
know you got to be smart oh wow really
that's the boys coming out of that body
surprised me but yeah he wished she had
a gun and you know what I can understand
where he's coming from if you saw this
walk into your office or neighborhood
you might feel the same way it looks
like your next lexa gig there and it's
taking everything I have to not reach
for my concealed carry piece right now
and you know what else the reason I want
to stay here with you I have a reason to
live Thomas soul coming up after the
break right now
oh I'm excited nervous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright I'm so glad to have our next
guests on I had to actually someone the
rare instances I had to go into my
office and just kind of meditate during
the break kind so many questions I
wanted to ask there are only a handful
of people one of whom we've already had
on Georges st. Pierre in athletics we
had him on the show Norma Donnell and
comedy hopefully someday and then when
it comes to economists social thinkers
philosophers this next guy for those of
you who don't know he's an American
economist social theorist I guess
political philosopher currently a senior
fellow at the Hoover Institute and his
latest book is discrimination and
disparities though it is one in a long
catalogue of many and one of the people
I look up to most mr. Thomas soul thank
you for being here sir thank you for
having me well listen I always wanted to
ask you this because I've always
wondered do greats know when they are
great and I've talked about this in the
show you know black rednecks and white
liberals was huge economic facts and
fallacies for me growing up and in
college where they teach Karl Marx I
said well I should teach Adam Smith
Keynes Hayek and I had to learn Chomsky
I've always said I wish they put Thomas
Sol as mandatory reading alongside of it
how does it feel to be arguably arguably
the most influential certainly probably
the most influential conservative
economist of our time I know I know you
have to be humble but has it set in I
mean cuz you're that guy well I I never
contradict the opinions of people who
say say good things about me but I
really don't it would be impossible to
be objective about oneself that's why I
never try the impossible well okay
that's a brilliant answer and I will
tell you this I never have felt better
about myself than seeing when I was
doing research on you recently seeing
people insult Thomas solo I realized it
doesn't matter who you are they called
him a racist and a dummy I'm like if
they say it about Thomas so I don't even
try to appease them let me ask you this
in your longest I know obviously you'll
say the latest book for
no discrimination and disparities is
incredible and I'm sure you considered
among your best but with such an
extensive catalog for a lot of young
people watching today who may not be
super familiar with you you know 18 year
olds if you had to pick one or two of
your books as sort of your crowning
achievement or the one you'd recommend
most is there one that sticks out well
if it's the one who'd I recommend most
it would be basic economics yes because
that's where most people are most
lacking and so there are other books
I've written that represent more of an
intellectual effort on my part but that
that's really not the criterion when
you're recommending something for their
benefit and now that's the book that has
in fact sold the most copies and been
translated into the most foreign
languages yeah and it was it was
fundamental for me I talked about its
growing up in college I remember I was a
conservative by nature but I said where
do I really go if I really want to learn
and read up on this and someone actually
gave me I think was actually basic
economics handed it to me and that was
my start so an incredible book for those
who are in their formative years let me
ask you about this latest book I want to
talk about this discrimination in
disparities for people who don't know
it's available pretty much everywhere
because he's Thomas Sol more relevant
today than I think possibly in my
lifetime for both the right and the left
I don't know if you've seen this quite a
bit sort of with the rise of this new
right contingency the left is either
inaccurate or misleading we know in so
many facets of the economy culture not
the least of which is how these identity
politics but now there's this
contingency and Jared was talking about
this on the right not the mainstream
right but semi friends who play the same
game namely they claim that race largely
determines IQ IQ largely determines
socioeconomic status thus different
races are doomed a different
socio-economic fates period your book
posits a very different argument doesn't
it and a very convincing one oh well yes
the the two main explanations of
disparities in the 20th century and into
our own time are one genetic and to
discrimination and the irony is that
American progressives have taken the
lead took the lead in both those cases
that is a hundred years ago American
progressives were completely on the side
of genetic determinism yes by the end of
the 20th century they want the opposite
end of the spectrum
and now all the disparities would due to
discrimination and it said because
there's a tendency of intellectuals to
go for one factor explanations and in
point of fact that there are so many
different factors that is virtually
impossible that there could be any such
thing as equal outcomes for different
groups let me give you one simple
example there's ignored almost
universally different groups have
different median ages Japanese Americans
have a median age of 50 right Mexican
Americans have a median age of 26 now
why would you ever expect to see
japanese-americans represented among
baseball stars even though Bank
Americans a hugely over-represented
among the leading baseball players right
I why would you expect a group with a
median age of 26 to be represented in
professional occupations like say
surgeons or high managerial executive
positions that require long years of
education and long years of experience
how many 26 year-olds from any ethnic
background would qualify some assist
jobs but the discussions go on is if age
is not a factor right absolutely this is
also true internationally I mean there
are any number of countries where the
median age is over 40 and in many other
countries
where the median age is under 20 there's
no way you should expect them to have
the same outcomes when those outcomes
require a great deal of knowledge
experience and so on yeah absolutely
it's a great point and obviously one of
the main macro points in your book which
is the same thing in media you know you
see it with obviously I think the median
age of Fox News viewers is in their 70s
and so the ads are different the same
thing when we went to ever we were
looking at at sponsorships we said well
Han people actually watch the show for
an average of half an hour or more is
what what do you mean that determines
the ad rates how long people stay with
it
time is a huge factor what you often
don't necessarily see discuss could you
maybe expand on most of the myth that if
not for discrimination society would
have equal representation
in careers income education and
incarceration because that's the huge
sort of I guess main tenant of leftism
that's taught on campus if not for
discrimination we'd all have these equal
representation outcomes you put your
finger on the key assumption on which
the holes it's like the Keystone that
holds up the whole structure and you
remove that and they don't have her and
what agent is one of those things but
what people desire to do matters right
ah you know for all I know I might have
been born you know with genes that would
have enabled me to become another new
Rudolf Nureyev is a male ballet dancer
okay if I was it was a total waste of
genes because where I grew up
nobody it was thought of no no guys ever
thought about becoming male ballet
dancers so it doesn't matter what their
abilities were it doesn't matter whether
they were was the opposition or the
gates of opportunity were wide open they
weren't going to become male ballet
dancer but what people want to do is
huge right yeah and you look for example
I mean why are there no Asian American
basketball players because they don't
want to play basketball
welcome say maybe height height plays a
factor as well there but but but again
with age you don't find Japanese
Americans as baseball stars right there
are baseball stars of Japanese ancestry
every one of them was born in Japan they
were not Japanese Americans right yeah
and when you look into either people or
nature you find disparities everywhere
all over the world at all kinds of
things and yet when you come to people's
talk the talk is about how everything
would be even its yeah let me throw
another one it's just lay on the point
geography you know people who live up in
mountains and on any continent are not
the same as people who live in river
valleys the people in river valleys
almost invariably have higher incomes
more education there
or advance the people in the mountains
tend to like behind one study was gonna
be a coastal people Senate seem to be
far more prosperous and people to live
in land one study pointed out that
something like 8% or the world's
population lived on coasts in the
temperate zone but they but they produce
something something like this without it
but eight percent no eight percent of
the land is like that
yeah but 23 percent of the world's
population lives there and they produce
53 percent of the world's output I mean
the circumstance is a matter hugely and
those seconds answers almost never the
same for everybody that's very
interesting you know that you bring it
up I would wonder if we would talk about
that the economic disparity the coastal
cities there's sort of that legacy
wealth because back in the day before
technology you had to be on the coast
right for mainline shipping any kind of
you want to do any international
commerce and again that's one thing you
could look at it as geography or you
could look at it from some kind of
economic standpoint you know something
that was really telling to me when we
were just talking about socialism and
I'm sure you're familiar with this you
just talked about geography when we talk
about Denmark and in these Norwegian
countries and we talk about their
economic status one thing that's often
not mentioned is actually swedish it's
true they do better than the average
American but Swedish Americans Danish
Americans on average have a 55 percent
higher life at life lifestyle and life
expectancy what's the word I'm looking
for here no I'm trying to think of
what's the word see what Thomas oh I get
nervous a quality of life quality of
life 55 percent higher quality of life
on average then the Danes in Denmark and
that's something that again will throw
it out throw everyone for a loop when
you bring that up and it's what it's
very easily found yes yes no I and a
previous book I went into these
Geographic differences and they're just
astonishing and sometimes it takes this
one when in the old this discrimination
of this barry's book in this first
chapter I go into the fact that the
firstborn child does so much better than
the later born children yes and here you
have both the heredity and the
environment is the same as these are
normally defined
yet you find a complete
over-representation of firstborn
children and of the only child in so
many areas one strikes out strikes me at
once is uh astronauts the Apollo
astronauts who got a man on the moon 29
of them 22 of them were either firstborn
or an only child
well that is that does do it do we have
any simile we don't fully know but I but
I make make the orbit and show some
evidence that it's the parental input
but the because the only kind of child
it does better than the firstborn is the
only child and what he gets that the
others don't get is full parental
attention the firstborn is an only child
for a while yes so this I think that's
that's crucial I also if you look at
twins twins average several points lower
IQ than people who are born a singly and
yet those those where one of the twins
is stillborn or dies early then the
other one has an IQ not very different
from those of people who are borne
singly so parental input is just huge
yeah and that varies enormously from
group to group yeah it is fascinating oh
I believe my producer so that I mean
that what you're saying is that would
mean that the first few years of
someone's life are incredibly formative
if that's because that's only a period
of time they live without would live as
an only child it would seem I'm gonna
get equally to children of the parents
you have to split time once do you think
that's a big reason why mr. solo in
formative years earlier yes in fact in
doing the research I thought of my own
life and my parents lived out a normal
life I would have been the sixth child
in the family they thought they both
died young oh well I was raised from
infancy in as an only child and a family
of four adults a complete huge different
difference from what would have been
otherwise well so their great misfortune
and my good fortune I was going to say
that explains why such an overachiever
Thomas so rest of us look like bottom
dwellers any poor parents not yeah yeah
exactly that's exactly what you need let
me ask you this for two final questions
how much does IQ itself determine
status that's obviously a big point of
controversy with different factions
right now and I know you'd write about
in your book but for people who are
listening or watching well I guess
there's a high correlation between IQ
and success in a lot of areas right what
else I also point out in the first
chapter of my book there are people who
never made the IQ cutoff of 144 a major
study at Stanford who went on to win a
Nobel Prize in Physics and and yet none
of the fifteen hundreds of people who
who did make that out that IQ cutoff
none of them want to Nobel Prize in
anything so it's not it's not
determinative
I think the IQ itself is a product of
circumstances and that's true the phrase
born has a higher IQ than his siblings
right after him right that is
fascinating and I know I know a lot of
people you know a lot of people have
been arguing the opposite but this book
puts forward a tremendous case let me
ask you a final question here because
like so obviously right now I'm sure
you're well aware the gun debate going
on in the country and you've waited in
this before
um at what point do we say ok here is a
clear-cut case where you know
correlation to causation here we can
look at this graph and determine it one
to me that stands out we've been talking
about this quite a bit with the gun
debate you know ninety-eight percent of
public mass shootings occur in gun-free
zones seems to me that's pretty
cut-and-dried one that's never talked
about in your opinion when does it cross
that barrier where okay we can
definitively say this is the reason well
I think for those we're going to show
people it will never cross that barrier
because they will never discuss in those
terms when was when did you ever see any
gun control advocate come up with
numbers of show that gun control reduces
murders there's a huge volume of
evidence out there you think of it
during 50 states each having all kinds
of different gun laws there are all
kinds of ways they could be compared
think of all the countries around the
world with different gun laws different
periods of history when there were
different gun laws and so you have a
mountain of evidence if you were looking
for evidence instead they just simply
assumed from day one that if you have
tighter gun laws you'll have less murder
rates
and there there's tons of empirical
evidence pointing just in the opposite
direction right yeah it really is the
MPA that's it's a very important point
mr. soll empirical data just like when
we talk about health care and people say
well do you like your health care and it
goes by a pono whole second let's go by
mortality rates let's go by weight times
let's go by empirical data and that is
the world in which Thomas soul lives the
book of course is discrimination and
disparities disparity I'm just all I'm
nervous I will admit I'm nervous I'm
nervous here this guy is a rock star to
me mr. soll I thank you so much for
being on the show and look forward to
anything you put out I can't thank you
enough
thank you for having me absolutely and
after this with Owen Benjamin there's a
change it's that time the single live
read of the week in because we've had so
many new people coming in we're gonna do
another mug Club live read often it's
been been Walter but by the way hit the
notification bell if you're on YouTube
watching this ladder with credit calm
slash mug Club its $99 for the year or
69 for students veterans active military
and there's a free month trial I think
the one on right you know let me let's
say well what is it exactly well what is
it it's what allows us to continue doing
the free content on YouTube and on
Soundcloud an iTunes it's what allows us
to do it so getting free clips up every
day it's what keeps everyone employed
here the 15 people across the website
and YouTube because YouTube ain't paying
us nothing but also you get the daily
show every day what you see is a clip
but what you see on Thursday we do that
every Monday through Thursday and not
get jeered show morning grinders sure
and Gavin McGinnis is there phil
robertson is there mark levin is there
roaming millennial is there I don't know
they're a bunch of people so you get you
get you get your money's worth
we do this because we don't want to have
our hands out with the cops saying hey
just you know exact up or say hey let's
we're gonna give you something exactly
either either the show watching the show
every day is worth it and all those
other people or it's not we don't do the
patreon thing we really do want to keep
this to be sure that you don't want to
watch or you don't so a lot of Scudder
dot-com slash mark but we really
appreciate the support if you want the
show to keep going that is what and of
course you get this hand etched
hand-painted or her theme ugh it is so
thick that mug though in that list of
this
[Music]
little change of pace from Thomas soul
ah what an accomplishment well I'm
really glad to have spoke with him and
this was this is the last-minute booking
we originally yeah we just call we're
ahead no and somebody said let's just
let's just crap the bed yes and bring on
somebody who leaves a wake of
controversy wherever he may go I was
gonna plug his Twitter but I don't know
what he's not on the Twitter and I know
he's suspended or something I don't know
what's going on on YouTube so we had
Dinesh D'Souza since he's obviously a
good friend of the show and we spoke
with him this morning because he helps
write for this show on occasion all this
happened between this morning and now
huge pianists calm pianist calm pianist
Thomas is special and he has a own own
Benjamin what's your patreon again
patreon /wd TL for why didn't they laugh
WD TL speaking of not laughing it seems
like Twitter and YouTube or not having a
guffaw now please explain overnight they
took out Owen Benjamin and then I had a
backup one called Owen bear Djimon that
I was I had on you know and the back
burner in case they took me out and they
took that out too and then they made it
like I mean take out are you suspended
are you banned suspended permanently I
believe because everybody I saw a little
widget pop up that said Donald Trump jr.
no longer fouls you and then I realized
that they blocked everyone and followed
me and unfollowed everybody and then
suspended me huh yeah heard of that yeah
it's really I think it was something
that happened and an upper management
because it was I think they got because
I don't even know how they knew about
Owen Baird umen uh I don't think it said
hard to figure out I don't think you
didn't act with like a trail of
breadcrumbs like they'll never find me
see it's pretty easy to Hansel and
Gretel Owen bear German and if you
didn't tell them all the unbearable --zz
who follow it did immediately so meet
him and Owen Baird him in and they're
like haha no more bear Jimin like well
that was easy
so what happened why were you and you've
lost your life streaming on YouTube so
you still have YouTube but it's just a
strike so that's good people
know that you're not banned from YouTube
hopefully we'll talk about that some
time off air and see what we can do but
sometimes if it's a community guideline
it's like no one knows what their
policies are well what was it what was
the violation here it was about David
Hogg
no no I said I said a comment about how
he hasn't he doesn't have pubes yet so
he can't tell a grown man how to rather
not I can own a gun and so that just
went wild I've never seen anything go
like that it was like a huge in
retrospect would you not at reply the
seventeen-year-old with the with the
pubes comment do you think like if you
went back like a maybe I can see an
Achilles heel to that to it I do like
like I do tree work for a living like I
actually was in this cold today so I'm
around men that talk like that where
they're like ah someone without any
pubes doesn't get to tell me where I eat
dinner that's just that's nothing to do
with the him being a it just got so like
twisted and I and I'm like no obviously
you know what I mean
right and and then it just kept going
and I realized that that kid it's like
all the flat comes from any criticism
that kid because when the YouTube thing
happened the shooting I said don't worry
David hog is rollerblading over to save
the day and that's what started a lot of
like firing at me I saw the blue
checkmarks get released and all the bots
start coming out and I was racing myself
because I've been through this before
like with the trans kid thing or when I
called Justin Trudeau a few racial slurs
um
wait hold on or the racial slurs it's
because he's like 118th Cherokee Nation
or just racist white guy slurs well I
was call him a snow monkey and a nice
back and all the stuff and they were
trying to make it seem like I was a
racist I'm like well he he's a white
person trying to get rid of the word
mother and father I was trying to make a
statement about a censorship I actually
jungwirth you could you obviously you
guys get it no I get it but shut down
well I you know one thing I will say and
that the obviously listen is that's it's
the question is not okay are these the
rules its are they applied equally and
if you go and you look at people are
left who I mean
people who put up fake Nazi memes of
myself and professors who retweeted no
punishment whatsoever so the real
question is the man we bumped you for
yes this is the law quite equally Dinesh
has talked about that um in this case
it's that's that's that's pretty cut and
dry but it I also always talk about
don't give them a reason and I have
looking they're looking for a reason to
say you're harassing this kid and so
looking back I'm like oh I want I wonder
if a party you might go like okay they
were looking for a reason and even
though that's not what his men is
clearly twisting shouldn't have just
done the ad reply yeah yeah no like
looking back I can see some as I said
earlier a few Achilles heels but uh and
the problem is you have so many
followers too so then the kid gets a
bunch of at replies and it bothers him
uh you know if you were nobody he
wouldn't care I'm almost like PETA from
from Hunger Games where the state takes
them some kid you know and they make
them say all this stuff and so I just
feel as a comedian I get to say the
hyperbole and the ironies and the satire
is that a lot of academics and
politicians aren't allowed to say it
I've always enjoyed that like position
of mocking power but in this situation I
mean you got to give it to him for
getting a 17 year old kid to try and
take down our right to bear arms it's
it's a tricky situation and I do regret
giving them ammunition against people
like us but at the same time you know
it's it's tough it's tough to realize
that when I do a tweet it's not just for
the people that follow me and know my
humor it's for the world these are
things that we're all facing now is it
is a global species about how to deal
with the Internet and how to deal with
the fact that the whole world can now
see that I I'm mocking that he doesn't
have ball hair and it's and this this
stream just gotten rubes Thomas so like
hey I was just recently appearing on the
where is it by the way great book one
last plug highly recommended Thomas all
you said you you've read Thomas so
literally changed my life yeah it it
should be mandatory reading for every
American I was just saying about
economic facts and fallacies but his
latest book is great and it's just as
relevant like I was saying for the left
and sort of the fringe all right with
this whole racial like you you know
you've heard this now some people
unfortunately have have taken ownership
over identity politics on the right
but you know I was talking about this
earlier the fact that someone on so
regardless of the Twitter thing Owen
Benjamin is funny so sometimes what
inspires me is not what people say or
what how people compliment them but the
insults and like I was saying earlier I
was feeling down because we just talked
about the social media you know we've
had this exponential growth and so it
sucks I don't really get to go on social
media and even see my fans cuz there's
so much negative feedback and sometimes
you want to hang out with your buddies
and we're all learning how to process
this as human beings we ever had this
and we had we were able to have a circle
of friends just like you said it's kind
of hard to imagine people who hate you
looming looking for that to happen but
back to my original part was Thomas soul
someone just said it today and it made
me feel so much better about myself they
said he's a tremendous dad I was
thinking you can't fight anyone more
cerebral or civil than Thomas soul so if
they're gonna send about him like oh
thanks for making my job easy it's the
same thing when someone says oh when
Benjamin sucks he's not funny or I've
had it with Nick DiPaolo or Jim Norton
to be in the show going on a second I
questioned myself but I don't question
that
Owens funny or that NICTA makes it easy
probably wrong about me even if course
it's so funny cuz a lot of people have
been saying that now or they're like oh
yeah well you're a hack who doesn't do
anything I'm like I've had to up
self-produced to our specials this year
and I've had two specials with Comedy
Central and another with another company
that's five in the last four years you
know it's the same thing it's like if
someone said that steven crowder isn't
ethical it's like a joke it's almost
like the exact opposite it's like yeah I
bet you would I bet you would think it's
ethical if you're hanging out with
Crowder like me like I bet you would
think it's funny if Owen Benjamin helped
write it for the show Mike yes all right
what was it where's the best place to go
to support you we wanted to fit you in
today we don't have a ton of time
where's the best it means so much to me
that you guys have me uh huge pianist
calm just is my height in my piano and
that's where you get the specials and
then off patreon.com slash wdt l like
you can just do the minimum blow to
youtube right you just can't live stream
I can still upload to YouTube Owen
Benjamin comedy and then uh yeah I don't
know what the future holds for me but uh
I love you guys well we'll keep us
posted and
just do me a favor before we go a lesson
be careful with YouTube just like just
don't do anything that'll get that
removed because we need you on there so
consult us okay this week oh I guarantee
you laid it this week everyone go
subscribe at Owen Benjamin comedy and
support them we have to go last segment
for this Thank You Owen Benjamin I much
love you guys
[Music]
all right all right now time to call
this double-secret patriarchy meeting to
order first item of business um
it's imperative that women don't catch
on to the fact that marriage is merely
glorified rape so let's all do our best
to keep it under a hat shall we
fantastic on to item number two we need
a new unified set of standards on what
will be determined as the most updated
yet of course very oppressive standards
of beauty for women that we don't even
like any ideas suggestions from anyone
the room is open now is your time to
shine yes Bradley what if we told the
magazine companies like that made the
magazine fronts that we all like robust
bosoms and hips we plant the idea of an
attraction to healthy mammaries and
birthing hips even though we don't like
boobs and butts brilliant that's a sure
way to get their goat anyone else have
any ideas yeah like what if we told him
we like them to smell good like we can
give them perfume and and uh oh
like shampoo even though we prefer slimy
rotund land manatees we convince them
that we actually round you hygienic
behavior Karla's any way we can
implement some kind of mind control
chemicals and those products while we're
at it a new boss and many give him some
sort of a slogan to really ingrain it in
their pressed subconscious something
like because you're worth it only a
little more creative little S on the
nose
absolutely and yet a slogan ideas about
maybe something like maybe she's born
with head or more maybe or or maybe it's
mabeline get out
[Music]
[Music]
dr. Sol dr. your fangirling so hard you
forgot to I know you know why I screwed
okay now thank you so much dr. Sol and
Owen Benjamin the reason was because
well you know we just will be releasing
this next week the Dean of UTA oh dear
I've said too much
dr. and was like please don't refer to
me a doctor refer to me by my first name
yeah so the last thing in my head
because sometimes I got a thing about
that they don't want to be pretentious
and doesn't say doctor his book just um
maybe Tommy maybe like also I'm I'm cars
to dick I didn't you know there's no way
around it doctor so oh why should we're
not gonna let me forget that during oh
look you missed your word forgot the
doctor all right - not any we know
things happen sometimes sometimes you
you're not having your best batting
average we have had we've had a busy and
you know a rough I've had a rough to
expect I will never fully tell you about
Illinois driving out there which was
terrible doing the show with quote
unquote not non-credible security
threats there were so ever tensions were
high and then there's just a busy busy
week with a lot of stuff to be taping
you and I actually have private
engagement to do on Saturday with with
Dean Cain I'm going to corporate gig in
a long time but it's actually a good
friend of Dean Cain's I just been going
burning the candle at both ends should
probably slow down but um you know we
were talking before we move on I realize
just just just to remind you this is the
face of insanity
[Music]
[Music]
see I didn't say on event
yeah why if you were going to put out
videos why don't you just learn the
language yeah mid skim milk you're gonna
see what are these two what makes them
key lights that means you know I have no
idea how to learn how to chroma key
that's what's most disturbing it's the
lack of quality quality in chroma keying
it's the lack of quality and you know
listen what what I think we'll be the
first to admit that some other thing
that we've done the last couple of
experiment with some new things some
things work some things didn't Ellen oi
we put on a show for the students period
it's not what change my mind is really
meant to be and we got out there there
were way more people than we expected we
could not have a security done properly
instead we're just a little bit tense
probably will be doing it again change
my mind is meant to be just sitting down
and kind of conversational but you know
what don't even announce that usually we
go places no we never end up there like
hey the whole goal is to not have an
audience but at this point we were kind
of we're kind of between a rock and a
hard place because we wanted a fans to
have some kind of a show that we could
do that was secure a turn turns out it
wasn't really anyway when we went out
here have this spot that we anticipated
so a lot of stress but you know what a
big reason for it and the big reason
we'll keep experimenting with new things
and sometimes that work sometimes they
don't we appreciate you allowing us that
flexibility we've talked about this
after SMU was definitely probably the
most it was the most visceral sort of
moment that I've had in a while I was oh
wow ok a lot of people are coming up
saying how important this was and this
this show it's a late-night comedy show
I am NOT dr. Thomas soul okay I am NOT
at am ready cuz III do not want to be
your only source of information I want
to be that we want to be the show you
can you can go to sleep with and enjoy
yourself and have a laugh and not want
to punch yourself in the face we want to
sleep with you yes pretty much to take
away there we want we want to teach you
and sleep with you we basically want to
be that college professor some emails
one of them I was talking about at
Illinois and here's another one we'll
keep his name and any any uh any other
sort of specific references secret but
this is something that and I think you
can take something like this and this is
something we've always talked about you
can take this kind of feedback from
people and you can use it to build
yourself up you can exalt yourself or
you can be humbled and genuinely want to
read something like this I will I will
meditate on it for a long time and think
gosh I mean we have a responsibility we
responsibility first and foremost to
entertain
but a lot of people we've talked about
we felt alone before we did the show a
lot of people felt that way but for them
this is this is their only you you see
that a lot when we do these egg
meet-and-greets you get to meet people
you're like I bet these people don't
these are the people who these aren't
the jocks and no popular kids at school
these are the kids these are the misfits
yeah exactly yeah that's one thing too
you know when the left tries to cover
the show like uh it's for dumb jocks
actually no we can look at exactly who's
watching when they're watching it is it
is the marginalized people yeah it is
the marginalized people and they're
terrified and this is an example
actually of someone from Saudi Arabia
who was well let me read his letter for
us it's a little bit long but I hope you
go with me on this here again trying to
omit with the overlays anything specific
so forgive me for looking down on my
iPad I'm reading his letter I don't know
it by heart
the day of the SMU show I had planned to
spend a night in Dallas to save some
money on transportation so I brought my
backpack but couldn't find a place to
stay without a photo ID since all ice
gave me was a paper parole document
that's relevant later the ice thing it
amazed it amazed me when I sat here and
read the full letter I managed to watch
the show after leaving the backpack in a
friend's car that I met there but he had
to leave a bit early and I couldn't go
into the mug club alone the after show
what's the backpack and couldn't find a
place to leave it English is not his
first language by the way so don't don't
don't hammer me or him on it now that I
got that out of the way I was an atheist
for a long time since my early teens
mostly due to YouTube and other online
sources after wanting to research some
parts of Islam to not sit too well with
me at the time naively think that the
people around and not Islam itself were
the ones with the bad ideas I later
found out about your show during the
gamergate days and got into politics
since and more so during the election
mostly behind fake random names on
Twitter that will not that's how it
often starts years earlier I managed to
score he wrote years earlier time so I'm
trying to trying to fix the we
appreciate it sir the person email list
he knows who he is this is not to give
you flak I'm just correcting it as I go
years earlier I managed to score a
government scholarship and left the
hellhole that is Saudi Arabia you said
it not me and in early 2017 during my
third year in a university in blank they
suddenly canceled my scholarship due to
quote not performing well enough which
did not hold up when I compared my
scores to other Saudis in the same
scholarship a usual thing in the Saudi
government is when they suspect someone
abroad of commenting a thought crime
is to make a random reason to call them
back then deal with them inside the
country to avoid any international
scandal since I liked my head where it
was
I got a tourism visa to the US and
applied for asylum once I got here and
due to a misunderstanding at the airport
interview I ended up spending some time
in ice detention which wasn't all that
bad really this is where I started to I
mean I can't even necessarily put into
words which wasn't all that bad really
can you picture any American talking
about those kinds of conditions an ice
detention center which wasn't all that
bad really and wanted to describe it he
said the food was very good some days
even at the time I was very open-minded
when it came to Christianity mostly due
to your show and people led me to like
Andrew Clayman and others the only
problem in detention ever where there
was all this free time and a lack of
good novels to read in the library in
the excuse of a library they had the
syntax was off so I got it wrong I
apologize so I ended up reading the
Bible a lot and talking with some
Christian detainees and later went to
Bible studies often a few months later I
got paroled from ice thanks to having a
plausible reason for asylum and no
criminal record in any country I've been
to since then I've been going to church
whenever I could my sponsor gave me a
trailer to stay at and I'm managing fine
I'm just waiting to get a work permit
these days which is taking a lot longer
than expected but I still want to do
this right
so I'm trying my best to hold on and
avoid getting any illegal jobs until
then I'm sure that true freedom will be
worth it in the end thank you again for
all the hard work that you do with I
know that it must be very hard on your
in sometimes but please remember the
show means a lot to many of us out there
who may not be able to speak up and have
a voice of their own the fact that it's
entertaining helps to warm regards the
ex Oddie fan and he went on to specify
his name now I read that and I read it
and we could read and go yeah it has
been hard I mean many of us have gotten
we've been getting by in five hours
might sleep for a couple weeks now but
no probably nowhere near as hard as
being in an ice detention center and
probably nowhere near as hard is facing
facing the magnitude of being called
back to a Saudi government that wants
your head on a platter who by the way
they're progressive because they have a
lot of female politicians true drive now
nowhere near as difficult is that
nowhere near as difficult as living in a
trailer
awaiting hopefully a work
visa and still trying to do the right
thing that's why when he says isn't all
that bad really and he goes on it's it's
not something it's not false humility
it's not him saying oh that's not that
bad
you can tell yeah this is a guy filled
with gratitude and so we read it when I
read this I can't feel any other way
other than grateful yeah we have some
pretty tough grinds and the truth is
we've had a lot of people come in to
work on this show and they left it was
like it's like a revolving door they
walk in and say nope they don't want
this work load it's it's not just
talking into a microphone everyone here
works really hard and that's what mug
club is so important we employ so many
people it takes a lot to make this show
happen it's hard it is difficult but it
is nowhere near as harrowing as the
prospect of the life that this man was
was facing I can't and can you even
imagine I can't imagine at all I we can
imagine being in Saudi Arabia for any
reason but certainly not with uh chasing
me down and you know what um we never
set out with listen not good you and I
are both most people here in this room
are Christians to one degree or another
it's pretty well known but we never set
out to try and convert people there are
enough you know Christian film there
enough churches you can go to for that
but there does need to be and we've
realized we serve as somewhat of a
bridge between the pastor and the sermon
and Amy Schumer hampster vagina barnyard
animal vagina right there's there's got
to be some kind of a bridge and we're
somewhere in between is what I would say
the impact that we've had with this with
this show and and we've gotten a lot of
flack in the last couple of weeks
because you become you know target
number one when you grow as quickly as
you have and again that's because of a
formidable team and because of people
like this this guy came ours guy not
only came across across the ocean to
United States but he came ours from his
trailer to make it to the SMU show and
he missed the after-party by the way
because the cops assured us out again
we've had a lot of lot of problems with
campus police being as accommodating as
as we'd like them to be I don't really
know necessarily where I'm going with
this all I'm saying is it's it's been a
weird couple of weeks where we never
really thought of ourselves as the kind
of people who would keep someone in an
ice detention center alive or someone
with PTSD who would say I feel less
alone than watching your show and it's
something that really that goes out a
lot and things maybe I'll get off my
chest
months from now looking back some
some personal issues that I've been
happening some health issues that have
been tough but how I look at it when I
read an email like this and not just to
this exercise every one out there
listening is I mean I I know you don't
owe your life to anyone but I really do
feel that way a lot of the time I really
do feel that we owe it to you not only
to continue doing the show to the best
of our abilities but when we thought
about all that we really want to fight
Twitter do we will want to fight YouTube
do we really want to have ville rich
that was a big decision like Bill
Ritchie on retainer is not cheap in SMU
law grad we said you know what we've got
it we've got it because someone out
someone out there has to do it just like
what the change my mindset but it isn't
meant to be a debate by the way but when
we have people on this show when we
invite everyone on to debate it's not
because I'm a debater I've never I never
claimed I'm a late-night host it's just
because no one else is stepping up to
the plate aside from a handful someone
has got to do it I'm not doing a lot of
this because I'm the best that's not why
any of us are doing it we do it because
of letters like these we do it because
at some point when you have a bunch of
people looking to you saying
hey can you can you get one over on them
for me you've got to say yes it really
is I don't want to say it's a selfless
endeavor of course it's not we all make
a living doing this but it is something
that I still can't begin to comprehend
and for which I am eternally grateful
and I want you to keep me accountable
I want you everyone in this room if you
say hey you know what I think you really
screwed up here or you know I think this
was wrong or you know I think maybe
you're you're getting off on the wrong
direction we want you to hold our feet
to the fire because we want the only
reason we're creating this is for you
this is one thing - that's a new concept
yet people want you here this I I just
make my art for me now you've got to
make art that's authentic and this is
this is art comedy is art you've got to
make art that's authentic you can't lie
people will smell it on you from a mile
away but you can't create art solely for
yourself the main purpose of what we
create here is not for us the main
purpose of it is is for you and even
more so after SMU and Illinois and
letters like these were overwhelmed with
the response I'm still continuing to
process it I know this isn't anything
particularly articulate usually you're
looking for some inspiring closing words
here's your that I can tell you I didn't
know how to feel ever since
a kid with SMU not with us ever since I
was a kid I dreamed of going into a
theater you know I would see Richard
Jenny was one when I was growing up and
I remember him in Montreal at a theater
with the st. Denis theater and I think
that maybe was 1800 going wow that was a
dream of mine that was a dream of mine
I'll just tell you everyone has your
dreams everyone has dreams out there
some are bigger some are smaller a dream
of mine as a kid was when I was watching
Richard Jeni and saw him doing that
theater sign man out to do that one day
so to go to SMU and have a theater fill
the 2500 seat theater filled with people
cheering and there for what we do for
what we create it's a if anyone else out
there and I guess I kind of its kind of
isolating because sometimes people don't
talk people talk about reaching for your
dreams or they don't necessarily talk
about achieving them it may not sound
like a big dream but it was for me as a
kid so when you're picturing us a
thousand times in your head first day I
didn't know how to feel in something
else you know I spoke with someone
recently a doctor funny enough blast
when I was stressed if I had any morbid
thoughts this is something often ask you
right and of course is why people are
afraid to answer honestly if we're
talking about gun control someone has
ever had a morbid thought so if you have
thoughts and I said well you know what
honestly I've pictured my death a
thousand times okay here pin drop what
do you mean so let me explain it to you
the same way that as a kid I probably
pictured a theater like us in here that
was the same to me theater I pictured it
a thousand times in my head I've told
Jared about this the visualization going
through what does the crowd look like
what does the air feel like what are the
lights like picture the sounds picture
the touch picture the the sights try and
put yourself there so it's not a foreign
situation to you I'm big on the power of
visualization not talking about
meditation or can't read yoga just
visualizing something before you do it
the same thing has happened because
listen we have had credible threats but
very serious very credible threats and
when you go out with the kind of
security detail that we have to have and
you know that there is this possibility
at some point in your life I told this
man I said yeah you know I pictured a
thousand times I have pictured walking
out inside picture the audience cheering
I've pictured the bullet going through
flesh I've pictured it breaking bone
what it would feel like I pictured the
screams I pictured the lights I pictured
the sounds I pictured the emergency and
I'll tell you this this is true and I've
pictured it because for the same reason
I've walked myself through jokes bombing
through
audience is being terrible I walked
myself through this because I always try
to picture getting back up I always try
to picture how I would deal with it and
you never do until you really you really
come into it but it's not because I want
to but I said I always walk myself
through that scenario in every scenario
that I can possibly imagine I get back
up and that reason is I wouldn't I
wouldn't if there weren't people there
who cared that's a huge component we
talk about mental health well people
just want to put it on a pill huge
component with these people these
shooters you look at YouTube they have
no structure they have no family
structure no communal structure they
don't have anyone who cares about them
and so when we go through weeks that are
really trying when we go through weeks
here in times that are incredibly
difficult some of us have some family
issues some of us said I've had some
really tough breaks I'm unless it had
deaths in the family we're going through
you know what keeps people going is
having people who care and I know there
a ton of people out there a ton of you
out there who care a letter like this
that can keep someone going for a long
time so it actually probably means more
to me than to you mr. X Saudi atheist /
Muslim and I hope you don't mind me
reading your letter on air dr. Thomas ol
thank you so much on Benjamin chin up
we'll see you next week
[Music]